-Welcome back, everybody.
We're here with the one and only
Michelle Pfeiffer!
Now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
In your new show,
"The First Lady,"
you play former First Lady
Betty Ford.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I know you've played
actual people before.
Is it more pressure to play
someone who exists or existed?
-It is.
-Because why? The family?
-Well, I mean, to play,
you know,
somebody who is historical
and one of our most popular
First Ladies ever --
-Yeah.
-She's more popular
than Gerald Ford.
And, you know, she's --
There's family
that are still living.
-Sure.
-And no matter --
And you kind of know that
no matter what you really do,
they're not gonna
like it so much.
-Yeah.
-You know? And you can't --
You can't be -- You want --
What you want to do
more than anything is honor her.
-Of course.
-And honor her legacy.
-Yeah.
-And you can't be 100% accurate,
because nobody was there
100% of the time.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And so --
But I was lucky in that there
was a lot of footage of her.
There was -- you know,
she did a lot of interviews.
Of course, she gave speeches.
-I don't really
know much about her, really.
-Well, not many people do,
and that's what was so exciting.
I mean, pretty much,
she's known for, you know,
the Betty Ford Clinic.
And she came out and she was
very vocal and very transparent
about her own drug abuse and her
substance abuse and alcoholism.
And that's pretty much
kind of what people know.
As if that weren't enough,
because she saved
hundreds of thousands of lives
with this clinic,
and continues to.
But she was --
What I didn't know was how
politically active she was.
She was incredibly vocal,
always getting into trouble.
You know, she --
-Big trouble.
-She was up to shenanigans.
She set up a command center
in the White House to lobby
to get the
Equal Rights Amendment ratified.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You were saying backstage, too,
that, you know,
you realize how powerful
a First Lady is, actually.
You know, what you can do
with that position.
-Well, they're quietly --
they're quietly kind of working
their own agenda, of course,
supporting their husband's
and supporting the presidency
because that's really
what their job is.
You know, they're out
always on the campaign trail.
They're always
campaigning for them.
They're always --
Wherever the president can't go,
they'll show up.
But they also -- you know,
they have their own voice.
And as she did.
And they're sort of
quietly working,
you know, behind the scenes.
And this is really about,
you know,
looking at the White House
through the lens of these women.
And, you know,
it's about Michelle Obama,
played by Viola Davis.
-Viola Davis, come on.
-And Gillian Anderson
plays Eleanor Roosevelt.
-Another. Come on.
-And you know, it's --
And they're incredible.
-That's fantastic.
Three of you together --
This is just awesome.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Michelle Pfeiffer as
Betty Ford in "The First Lady."
Take a look at this.
-If you think I want
what's being handed to me
from this administration,
and I realize my ambitions
have made life hard for you,
but you knew what you were
getting into.
-No.
I did not know
what I was getting into.
[ Clatters ]
But here I am.
And I will be here for you.
But I am going to be myself.
I am going to do and say things
that I believe in.
I think I've earned that right.
-Yeah.
That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is how you do it.
Michelle Pfeiffer, everybody.
"The First Lady"
premieres April 17th
at 9:00 p.m. on Showtime.